o papão
[Música]
desde que nascemos
até quando morremos sentimos medo eo
medo é um dispositivo de proteção da
vida todos os seres vivos têm medo uma
plantinha que se retrai
ela faz isso por medo a lula quando
solta aquele jato negro faz isso por
medo uma fera
se tá rugindo mostrando os dentes está
fazendo isso por medo também
agora o mais irônico é que eu aqui em
cima desse palco tô morrendo de medo
quando fui convidado para participar
eu comecei a tremer ainda por dentro eu
estou com muito medo lá atrás eu estava
fazendo todo joga e tal poder conversar
com vocês enfrentar o meu medo de ficar
de frente para uma platéia pra mim volta
na frente de um urso e o mais irônico é
que eu ganho a vida com medo eu sou
escritor de livros de terror
eu faço isso todos os dias mas parece
aqui contou na frente do palco que tem
uma fera olhando pra mim e não é à toa
que falar em público é um dos maiores
medos do ser humano
mas quando a gente está em frente ao
medo a gente vai investigar essa coisa
do medo a gente tem que escolher e eu
vou encarar o meu medo
em última instância o que a gente mais
teme é morrer já que o medo protege a
vida temos medo da morte medo de
desaparecer
nós temos medo de tudo o que pode nos
fazer mal fisicamente ou moralmente
psicologicamente
a gente fica aterrorizado as vezes que o
ser humano não é a espécie mais forte do
planeta é também não é mais inteligente
eu acho também visto tudo que a gente
faz nem com com nosso planeta
mas uma coisa eu tenho certeza
a espécie humana é mais medrosa que
existe e ainda bem
ainda bem que a gente tem medo ter medo
faz a gente seguir em frente sem medo
faz a gente se preparar e ter medo
protege o medo é uma emoção natural que
todos apresentam e que funciona como um
sinal de alerta e como eu disse se é um
sinal de alerta
o medo tá presente na nossa vida para
proteger não tem vergonha de ter medo lá
atrás no começo dos tempos
quando a gente começou a se aglutinar se
juntar como pessoas em bandos
a gente tinha muito medo e se a gente
tinha medo da natureza a gente criava o
que casas cidades queremos muros
se a gente estava com medo da fome
nós desenvolvemos agricultura religião
mitologia
tudo isso são filhos do terror do medo
pra gente explicar o que a gente
desconhece se a gente tem medo
começamos até medo dos conflitos
criamos a diplomacia criamos a lei
queremos o direito
tudo isso é evolução por conta do medo
mas o que é o medo o medo
ele é disparado é um mecanismo de
proteção disparado pela mídia ela
cerebral
ele vem antes da razão para você tomar
uma ação agora lutar fugir ou se
paralisar os 3 efes inglês que até
bonitinho né fight or flight freeze
fugir se você tá percebendo que está
havendo uma avalanche se preparar para
encarar uma fera e um predador ou se
fingir de morto fica paralisado katyn
até o perigo passar mas como isso começa
a amígdala cerebral é que nem um
cachorro que fica latindo pra gente isso
não liga se nosso medo instintivo e
lança na nossa corrente sanguínea
cortisol e adrenalina e aí a gente
começa a respirar mais rápido retorno
quando está com medo comecei a respirar
mais rápido o coração começa a bater
mais rápido pra que é para jogar sangue
nos nossos músculos pra gente reagir ou
fugir a essa falta de sangue é uma coisa
doida essa falta de sangue também nos
protege
porque se o sangue saindo para os
músculos falta em outro lugar porque se
a gente se machuca na luta
sandra - a barriga a gente tem sempre
aquele frio na barriga né
fico enjoado a bexiga relaxa da vontade
de fazer xixi
tem gente que urinou nas calças mesmo em
cima do palco assim sabe é a nossa
pupila dilata a gente ampliar o campo de
visão tudo isso para nos proteger
a pele fica pálida a boca seca ea nossa
mente começamos bombardear de
pensamentos de memórias negativas pra
você ficar atento fugir daquele medo e
aí você é empurrado para uma dessas três
opções ou você vai lutar ou você vai
paralisar ou você vai fugir e às vezes
como isso é tão rápido é feito por um
sistema de proteção é mais rápido do que
a nossa parte racional você fica você
não sabe se o medo é real ou se é
imaginado
às vezes ela imaginado e quando o perigo
passa na situação real agente fifa
sobrevivi me me livrei dessa mas quando
o imaginado isso começa a se repetir se
repetir se repetir por conta de stress
por conta de fobias por conta de traumas
isso nos faz muito mal porque a gente
não com um tá conseguindo distinguir
naquele momento que tipo de medo está na
nossa frente se ao real se imaginado a
isso vai virando uma patologia que nos
mobiliza e o problema é que hoje em dia
se mobilizar ficar apático não tomar uma
reação não faz bem
ainda bem que existem tratamentos você
pode tomar a medicação e atrás terapia
médico e as pessoas que sofrem com essas
doenças que te empurram para o medo
imaginado super justificável por conta
da nossa sociedade hoje em dia é
bombardeada pedida por tantas notícias e
até
cidades né e deixa a gente confuso mesmo
será que o medo é aquilo está
acontecendo aqui o medo está distante
e aí a gente precisa buscar o equilíbrio
desse medo e buscar o que é entender o
medo saudável
o medo bom um chamado assim que todo
mundo tem que volta no mesmo lugar
proteção é aquela coisa disse você vê o
manezinho chegando perto da tomada vai
lá e segura em um pandeiro e não um pai
que sai pra fazer uma viagem com a
família faz a revisão do carro antes
proteção
se você tem uma um sintoma de uma doença
mais grave você vai procurar um médico
tudo isso para nos proteger e apesar do
homem de testar o medo
ele procura o medo
isso é muito doido mesmo na sociedade
que já tem tanta agressividade tanta
informação negativa a gente procura o
medo porque a gente procura o medo não é
muito estranho que as pessoas paguem
para sentir medo
como eu disse eu sou escritor
escrevo livros de terror vem tem os
milhares as pessoas vão pra frente do
cinema em filas enormes para assistir
filmes de terror
filas enormes ou vão a parques de
diversão pra pegar montanha russa é em
casa mal assombrada a castelo do terror
né quem nunca
tudo isso pra sentir medo
aí o que acontece nosso cão de guarda
aqui amígdala cerebral ou em você
naquele estado de novo aquele sistema de
sobrevivência adrenalina e cortisol
volta e você sente todas aquelas emoções
sob controle quando acaba a experiência
você também sabe se está bem você foi lá
você experimentou medo e é viciante tem
gente que maratona e séries filmes de
terror assim tipo tempo todo tal medo
histórias se junta um pouquinho sempre
foram parentes próximos lembra de quando
a gente é pequeno e é pra dormir na casa
do primo da prima festa do pijama
separadas
a gente inventava histórias já desde
moleque desde criança que está
acontecendo
nossa barulho debaixo da cama debaixo da
cama não vai você e aquele vulto no
armário a gente provocam medo também
sentiu medo e ficava apavorado por um
instante e tal aí depois senti um alívio
né
todo esse sistema legal é que depois que
passa o medo e você detecta que acabou o
perigo
o cortisol e adrenalina baixo de novo e
você sente um alívio por isso as pessoas
adoram medo
estranho né o medo ea literatura tem
essa coisa em comum
quando estou escrevendo quando começa a
escrever um livro faço aquela coisa o
roteiro e tal e eu começo primeiro
capítulo o que vai acontecer agora e o
que isso escrevi a história que eu tenho
cá de alguma coisa atrás da outra
tem a ver com o medo a gente morre de
medo do desconhecido
a gente não aguenta o desconhecido nos
apavora e quando eu tô contando
histórias eu tenho que pensar o que vai
acontecer depois e quando a gente está
com medo a gente pensa no que vai
acontecer depois
e dá uma coisa para a raça humana é
incrível que o poder de você
prevê um futuro se preparar se proteger
o medo é sinal de proteção e você
consolida com o seu medo você se
transforma tem a chance de se tornar um
herói olhar para o futuro calcular o que
você vai fazer você pode enfrentar o
medo ou você pode desviar do perigo
não tem problema agir é coragem
quando você tem medo e olha que
interessante
os heróis não são aqueles destemidos que
não tem medo de nada
os heróis somos mais pessoas que
enfrentam o medo e quando você enfrenta
os seus medos
você vira protagonista da sua vida e
você rompeu essencialmente humano e
chega em outra esfera do essencialmente
divino porque isso acontece porque é
isso que os heróis são parte humanos a
partir de deuses e se você está vivo
aqui hoje agora se você enfrenta os seus
medos
mesmo os seus medos mais profundos
você consegue em frente se prepare desv
só não fica congelado
você se torna um herói também você é uma
pessoa corajosa um vitorioso
você venceu esse jogo do medo e eu tenho
certeza que a sua história vai ser
contada como de um herói que lutou
contra o medo e ganhou e venceu
é isso muito obrigado
[Aplausos]